now I'd like to introduce our feature
presenters today professors Jim leap and
Pamela Matson Jim directs with Fiorenza
miquellee the Stanford center for ocean
solutions and is the William and Ava
Christ fellow at the Stanford woods
Institute for the environment Jim has
more than three decades of conservation
experience spanning a broad range of
conservation issues on every continent
from 2005 to 2014 he served as director
general of World Wildlife Fund
international and leader of the global
World Wildlife Fund network before going
to World Wildlife Fund International Jim
directed the conservation and science
initiatives of the David and Lucile
Packard Foundation previously he served
as executive vice president of World
Wildlife Fund us in Washington DC as a
lawyer for the United Nations
Environment Programme in Nairobi Kenya
as a law professor and as a litigator
for the National Audubon Society and for
the u.s. department of justice he is
also a distinguished fellow at the
climate works foundation pamela is an
interdisciplinary sustainability
scientist academic leader and
organizational strategist the former
dean of Stanford University School of
Earth energy and environmental sciences
she is the Goldman professor of
environmental studies and senior fellow
at the woods Institute for the
environment and leads the graduate
program on sustainability science and
practice her research addresses a range
of environmental and sustainability
issues including sustainability of
agricultural systems vulnerability and
resilience of particular people and
places to climate change and
characteristics of science that can
contribute to sustainability transitions
at scale some of her over 200
publications include seeds of
sustainability lessons from the
birthplace of the Green Revolution and
pursuing sustainability
she's an elected member of the National
Academy of Science and the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and
received a MacArthur Foundation Award
among many other awards and recognitions
and with that let's turn it over to Jim
and Pamela good morning everyone thank
you for joining us for our strategies
for sustainability program today we're
going to be talking about a really
important type
of social capital that allows us to
address challenges very complex
challenges that span sectors and span
across spatial scales but before we
start that conversation I think it makes
sense to take a moment and ask what does
sustainability mean what do we mean by
sustainability of course this is a term
that's used by different people in
different ways but it's very commonly
used in the corporate world and their
corporate sustainability is about the
triple bottom line or the three-legged
stool it's about making decisions that
make sense economically but also
socially and environmentally and today
ESG is a central part of many
corporations business and why Department
wide of corporations do it I should just
say it's partly because it saves money
and reduces risk it helps recruit and
retain the best of the employees and it
also is because corporations care about
their communities in the world and the
other organizations that use
sustainability regularly is the
International Development community that
the community that's trying to help some
of the poorest places on the world in
the world develop socially and
economically over three decades ago it
was recognized that if we want to help
meet the needs of the present we have to
do so without compromising the future
and so sustainable development became a
major focus and it's been worked on for
many many years with quite a bit of
success and today the world is focusing
on the 17 SDGs or sustainable
development goals of the UN corporations
governments universities and other
research organizations NGOs foundations
are all working together to try to
address these goals what do they have in
common they both both uses of the term
sustainability and others are focusing
on the well-being of people and
organizations but not just today also in
the future and not just here where we
live but
all around the world and because of that
common focus I like to think about
sustainability as a sustainability goal
as that of intergenerational social
well-being so if we're using the word
well-being of people what do we mean by
that there's lots of different
discussions about what is included in
the term well-being but certainly it
includes meeting the material needs of
people for food and energy and water and
shelter and employment and so forth it
means addressing health issues and
meeting educational needs and providing
opportunities for people to choose for
example what they do with their life and
security and so on if you think about
how hard it is to achieve those that
goal of intergenerational well-being the
well-being of people not just today but
in the future you recognize the huge
challenges but many of us also recognize
the huge opportunities in doing so but
it is not easy and the the problem here
is that these kinds of questions that
we're addressing for sustainability and
for meeting the intergenerational
well-being of people around the world
are really complex problems and they
take place in highly complex systems
there's lots of different players lots
of different moving parts lots of
interactions feedbacks nonlinearities
and the fact is intervening in one area
may hate may have unintended
consequences for other price of the
system so changing a policy could have
impacts in many places that you didn't
expect them to occur or a new technology
could also have unintended consequences
so because of this complexity we believe
that it's very helpful to use systems
approaches to do systems thinking and to
utilize frameworks to help us design and
implement actions that address the goals
of sustainability despite
plek City so one such framework is this
shown here at the top you see well being
the constituents of well-being we talked
about before there are lots of
production and consumption processes
that we and you and all of us who are
actors and agents of change are carrying
out in try in trying to address that
well-being goal we could spend hours
days years talking about how those
production and consumption processes
could change but today let's just turn
to the fact that they they're they rest
on five major asset groups these
underlie our ability to produce and
consume well being the under liabilities
to meet that well-being challenge so
start with human capital this is just
the numbers of people our demographics
the the health of people the accumulated
knowledge that people have and these are
the things that allow humans to interact
in complicated systems social capital
includes the rules and regulations the
culture and cultural and social norms
the governance systems the networks and
the partnerships that allow us to work
together as we try to reach the
sustainability goal manufactured capital
includes everything we make its our
roads and our airports and our energy
plants it's our factories and the things
that we make in those factories it's the
new technologies that we're developing
including you know our handheld devices
it's books it's it's management
practices anything that we make natural
capital includes everything that this
planet offers us it includes ecosystems
landed in the oceans that provide so
many of the things we need it includes
water resources and soil resources our
climate system our atmosphere system on
minerals that we draw on and many other
things and then finally the fifth major
group of facets is knowledge capital
this includes the knowledge that we gain
from scientific research but it also
includes the knowledge we gain from from
practice from experience from
traditional knowledge so all of these
things work together to underpin our
efforts towards sustainability and if
one of them is missing we're not going
to probably make much progress in some
places for example what's missing is the
rule of law and it gets in the way of
communities trying to move towards
sustainability in other areas it might
be infrastructure in other areas that
might be depleted natural resources we
need them all and in many cases we have
to develop them grow them so that we can
meet our sustainability goals you have
to pay attention to all of them today
we're going to focus on social capital
and on one particular type of social
capital rather new rather challenging
and that is the use of partnerships to
address really really complicated
problems and to present this Jim leap is
going to take us through some cases and
some experience that he's had as both a
developer of these kinds of partnerships
and someone who's analyzing how well
they work so Jim over to you thanks Pam
as we are live in an increasingly
globalised economy the creation of
social capital it becomes ever more
important and in many ways ever more
challenging and that's what we want to
talk about a little bit this morning is
how do you create social capital in a
globalized economic sector as all of us
demand more and more from the earth we
are putting more and more pressure on
producers to expand production of
commodities such as soy or beef or
seafood or copper and as they expand
production they are putting more and
more pressure on the natural resources
the natural capital that supports us all
well in the context of fierce global
competition in global markets it's often
difficult for any one country to control
those forces and to manage its own
resources successfully and so success
will come from thinking much more
broadly about what kinds of
collaborations what kinds of
partnerships can actually drive
change and this is a complex of ideas
and possibilities that some have called
ecosystems of change it recognizes that
in a globalized economy change comes
from diverse actors not just government
not just companies but also NGOs civil
society organizations of other kinds
communities international organizations
engaged with each other in an evolving
set of interactions so those are
interactions that may take one form
early in a change process and evolve
significantly over time as these
collaborators interact and together our
finding ways to create solutions that
can meet these challenges and to drive
those solutions into implementation on a
scale that really will change outcomes
now for all of us the touchstone in
these efforts is that sustainable
development goals which provide us for
the first time a global agenda for
sustainability and these goals have
become increasingly a touchstone not
only for government actors but also for
many companies and for civil society one
of those goals is the sustainable
management of forests it's this goal
that I want to focus on this morning
this goal you will note calls among its
many targets for an end to deforestation
globally by 2020 which is after all next
year and it's a worth noting as we talk
about collaborations in this space that
we are not on a track to achieve that
goal in fact we saw record levels of
deforestation around the world in 2016
and 2017 but this is the target we've
set ourselves and it is the touchstone
for companies and civil society and
others to come together around trying to
change the direction of those curves the
big problem is clearing a forest for
agriculture or 71% of tropical and
sub-tropical deforestation comes from
conversion of forest lands to
agriculture and together agriculture and
deforestation account for nearly a
quarter of greenhouse gas emissions
globally so this is a big problem from a
forest loss perspective but also from a
climate perspective one of the biggest
culprits in driving deforestation is
palm oil especially in south
destacia and i'm gonna focus on palm oil
as a case study to look at how
partnerships are beginning to form and
and where they might go from here
we saw explosive growth in palm oil
production over the last half century
starting from virtually nothing in the
mid 60s
you see in the red line the growth of
palm oil production first in Malaysia
and then maybe 10 years later in
Indonesia Indonesia itself alone
accounts for more than half of all
global palm oil production today and
this is a product which you rarely know
you are buying but it is in half the
products in the grocery store it's in
the little tiny type on the back of each
package whether it is lipstick or cup
noodles or peanut butter cup noodles
thank you or peanut butter or soap or
shampoo or many other products and so it
is on the one hand ubiquitous on the one
hand hugely significant the most
important vegetable oil on the global
market and at the same time a very
difficult challenge to tackle because
nobody knows the routine palm oil you
don't think about buying palm oil and so
for many years it was very hard to get
at this problem and then in 2001 me
grown which some of you from Europe will
know is is a grocery chain in
Switzerland me grow came to WWF and said
how can we work together to address this
problem of unsustainable production of
palm oil globally and out of that
process out of that first engagement
came a small collaboration with a
handful of retailers and producers and
NGOs civil society organizations who
came together to begin to develop
principles for sustainable production of
palm oil and so was created the
roundtable on sustainable palm oil RSPO
an RPO those parties and a growing
number of stakeholders from each sector
work together over the years that
followed to develop a standard for
sustainability in that sector now if you
think about it for a minute you realize
that of course that's a daunting
undertaking because having all the
stakeholders together is essential for
credibility and could be essential for
impact
but it also makes it very difficult to
get to agreement on what a standard
should be and I think it's clear that
the RSPO has worked very hard over the
last 20 years over the last 18 years to
develop a credible standard it has made
huge progress in that time and it has
also demonstrated that progress is
challenging that it is almost inevitably
too slow for some actors and too fast or
too strict for others and RSPO has been
trying to wrestle those challenges to
the ground and has come up with a
standard that is increasingly the
touchstone in this section but while
RSPO wrestled with those difficult
problems to other insights really
changed the way civil society and
companies began to think about how how
change could happen in this sector and
the first was a recognition coming out
of WWF that there are in fact even in
these huge global sectors keystone
actors who really can be crucial in
driving change so if you take the
commodity sectors broadly not just palm
oil but also soy and beef and tuna and
shrimp you take those global commodity
sectors broadly they of course have now
7 plus billion consumers all of us are
consumers of products that come out of
those sectors and they have maybe one or
one and a half billion producers
fishermen and farmers who are growing
crops or catching fish around the world
that's a prude those are pretty big
numbers pretty hard to influence
directly the behaviors or practices of
one and a half billion farmers and
fishermen but there is connecting those
two groups connecting producers to
buyers there is a supply chain that
actually has a very pronounced choke
point and there are about idebenone s
estimate if you look across 15
commodities are the most important
commodities for driving biodiversity
loss around the world there are about
500 companies that control 70% of the
production and trade in those sectors
and that begins to become a very
manageable number that if you can reach
those companies engage them in
supporting change you can begin to make
a difference that matters globally and
the second insight and this example
comes from Oxfam the second insight is
that many of those big companies have
brands
consumer-facing brands and they are
often highly focused on the integrity
and reputation of those brands and that
means that NGOs civil society
organizations especially campaigners can
engage companies by engaging their
brands and so take two examples in the
case of palm oil one is Unilever
Unilever has for a very long time than
the world's largest buyer of palm oil
it's central to soap and margarine two
of their core products but many other
things they make as well and Unilever
makes dove beauty products and for many
years their campaign in support of
beauty products has been the campaign
for real beauty of which this ad is one
example
and so the 2008 greenpeace took off on
this ad to bring home the message that
that Unilever was buying palm oil and
therefore was part of driving
deforestation and this is an ad that you
meleave are pretty hard I mean this is
an ad that goes to the direct directly
to their brand positioning to their
reputation and to the reputation that
they have earned and continue to build
and so within a few days green Unilever
sat down with Greenpeace to begin to
talk about okay how do they shift their
purchasing to sustainably produce palm
oil reapeaks did the same thing with
Nestle Nestle of course one of the most
widely known brands in the food sector
an iconic brand for Nestle as KitKat and
if you haven't seen it it's worth going
on YouTube and and asking for Greenpeace
KitKat you will get the video that lies
behind this ad and what that video
brought home in a very vivid way was
that every time you are eat a KitKat bar
you are part of deforestation that
Nestle was part of buying palm oil and
therefore contributing to deforestation
in Southeast Asia
this hit Nestle hard and Nestle pushed
back for two or three four weeks on
social media and then Greenpeace
activists dressed as orangutans dropped
out of the ceiling of the Nestle Annual
General Meeting and brought home the
this connection brought home this issue
I'm talking to colleagues within Nestle
one thing that becomes clear is that
this initially felt like an attack on
company in the course of my but what
they realized is that it also as a
statement that Greenpeace a bit sorry
that Nestle was part of deforestation
and that is not something Nestle wanted
to be a part of an and so in the weeks
that followed Nestle also made a
commitment to addressing deforestation
and supply chain and it has worked very
intensively over the last several years
to deliver on that commitment so you
have a couple big companies that have
begun to make commitments that have said
we were going to address sustainability
of palm oil production in our own supply
chains but as they did that one thing
became clear which is that it is very
hard to do it as a single company to
drive that kind of change as a single
actor in a global and complicated sector
and so Unilever and Nestle and others
began to realize that they needed to
collaborate with their competitors so
having been engaged with NGOs like
Greenpeace and them with WWF and others
to figure out how to address this
problem they realized that everybody
would be better off if the whole
consumer product sector moved together
if if you'll ever ends Nestle and other
first movers were joined by other
companies in their sector and that would
be better for the forest because you get
broader change a broader commitment to
sustainability but it would also be
better for each of them because they
reduce the risk that by moving on this
issue
they created a competitive disadvantage
in the marketplace because others could
buy palm oil more cheaply and so
Unilever in particular led the creation
of a commitment in the consumer goods
forum to addressing deforestation
consumer goods forum which is about 400
companies adding up to more than two
trillion dollars in revenues who work
together on issues of concern to the
consumer products and retail sectors and
in 2010 this consumer goods forum
committed to addressing deforestation
and the companies and companies of the
consumer goods forum committed to
eliminating deforestation from their
supply chains focusing in particular on
palm oil also also soy beef and timber
and paper production which are the big
drivers of deforestation around the
world
so for the first time you have the whole
sector moving and saying we need
together to be coming to grips with
these problems a new kind of
collaboration among companies that
otherwise can meet can compete very
vigorously in the marketplace ok so that
gets you the ultimate buyers the
consumer products companies and the
retailers who are selling the ultimate
products but all of them are supplied by
traders and traders of course are
largely behind-the-scenes traders are
companies like Lamar and Cargill Archer
Daniels Midland who trade vast
quantities of commodity who have four
years traded commodities largely on the
basis of quality and price because
that's how those global markets work
into our largely out of the public eye
but as you saw more and more buyers more
and more of their customers making
commitments to eliminating deforestation
as you saw the deforestation issue rise
more and more on the public agenda with
campaigns against some of those buyers
and with broader campaigns then the
traders begin to engage this process
they were hearing from their customers
that they needed a deforestation free
supply they were hearing from campaign
organizations and others that this was a
cause they needed to join and Willmar
the largest single trader in palm oil in
2013 announced that it was committing to
be part of addressing this problem and
that it would eliminate deforestation
from its supply chains over the years
that followed so there you have it you
have the big buyers committed you have
one of the biggest traders committed and
then in 2014 the Secretary General of
the United Nations convened a climate
summit in New York it was aimed at
mobilizing action by actors across the
spectrum of my companies by national
governments by sub-national governments
to address the challenge of climate
change
hoping to build momentum going into the
Paris negotiations a year later and at
this climate summits through the work of
NGOs in Indonesia of Chamber of Commerce
and Indonesia of buying companies
trading companies you saw the four
largest producers of palm oil in
Indonesia and remember India
counts for more than half of all global
production you saw the four largest
producers of palm oil in Indonesia step
up and say they too were going to be
part of this movement that they would
commit to eliminating deforestation from
their production and so you get to 2014
that's well 13 years after me grow and
wvf started the roundtable on
sustainable palm oil about six years
after the first campaign against
Unilever 2014 you have 60 70 some would
guess 80% of the sector that is
companies that account for 60 70 80
percent of production committed to trade
eliminating deforestation from this
sector and that's a pretty remarkable
moment pretty remarkable to think that
that those companies that those actors
and NGOs could all come together around
this cause in such a complicated and
large economic sector and that led to
the creation of something called the
tropical forest alliance actually
formally announced in 2012 and then
expanded in the years that follow but a
recognition that a pre-competitive
collaboration among companies was
crucial but that actually this this is a
cause that required all hands on deck
that this required a collaboration among
those companies among buyers and traders
and producers but also that they be
joined by civil society organizations
both those who campaign on these issues
and those who provide who engage with
companies to help them figure out how to
solve them and it required participation
by governments by governments of
importing countries and by in particular
governments of producing countries and
so for example the tropical forest
Alliance was joined formally by the
governments of Malaysian Indonesia the
two most important producers of palm oil
as part of an effort to broaden this
collaboration and to find a way to make
progress together the same time you see
technology come in and technology really
will is already and will be increasingly
fundamentally important in creating the
dynamics around these kinds of
collaborations because as we know as we
get more and more granular information
about what's happening on the ground and
that information is more and more
real-time information or at least timely
information then companies and
governments and communities are more
accountable and they are more able to
take action than problems as they arise
and so for example a global forest watch
created by the World Resources Institute
developed something called the palm oil
risk tool which allowed it made it
possible to identify risks in the palm
oil supply chain where there were high
levels of deforestation or fire also
create a facility that would allow the
would send you an alert whether you were
a government official or a company or an
NGO could send you an alert if a fire
was spotted or forest was being cleared
and these tools get more and more
powerful every year and make it more and
more and more and more possible to
actually come to grips with these
problems together and to hold each other
accountable for progress now that's the
story that took us up through 2014
you saw a growing collaboration growing
engagement among these different actors
in trying to come to grips with the
challenge of deforestation on the ground
in the palm oil sector and then in 2015
we had an El Nino year and crisis hit in
that year you know August September
October there were more than a hundred
thousand fires across Sumatra and Borneo
the two largest islands of Indonesia and
those hundred thousand fires were almost
without exception intentionally set in
most cases to clear land for agriculture
but what happens in an El Nino year is
that fires once set often burn out of
control and many of these lands have
deep reservoirs of peat soil meters deep
which is coal in the making and which
can burn and burn and burn forever and
so fires once started often just burned
for weeks and months and we're very
difficult to point to put out this these
fires were a climate catastrophe in the
months of September and October 2015 on
most days all those yellow bars on most
days the emissions from these fires
exceeded the total daily emissions from
the US so huge and
Carbon put into the atmosphere over the
course of these fires but these fires
were also a public health and
development catastrophe
so the Harvard School of Public Health
has estimated more than a hundred
thousand people will have shorter lives
because of their exposure to the smoke
from these fires I was in Singapore
during the time of these fires while the
air on those days was was not too bad in
Singapore in Malaysia the average
concentrations of small fine
particulates were about 300 parts per
million the safety standard is a hundred
so the average level in Malaysia was
three hundred and they had closed all
the schools in some parts of Calem on
time the levels reached as high as 1500
parts per million so 15 times the safe
level so this was from a public health
perspective never mind the climate
impacts from a public health perspective
a disaster and it was also a development
disaster the World Bank estimates that
Indonesia took a 2% loss in global the
best domestic product because of the
damage of these farms and so all of a
sudden you see all of these issues come
together concern about forest protection
about climate but also about health and
development all converged in a shared
recognition that somehow we collectively
had to come to grips with the challenge
of fire in a deforestation in for palm
oil production and so in that year when
President jokowi shown here in this
picture began to put in place
restrictions to try and ramp up the
government of Indonesia's efforts to
address the challenge of palm oil and in
particular the Associated challenge of
fires he imposed a moratorium on the
conversion of peat lands for example put
in place a variety of other restrictions
and so then you had government's
creating more actively engaged in this
broad effort of coming to grips with
this problem now there is hope on the
horizon last year we saw a downtick in
primary forests lost in Indonesia you
see that it's been quite persistent over
the last several years as demand for
palm oil continues to put pressure on
those forests you
dropped last year last year was a wetter
year it wasn't as dry as 2015 and 2016
so there's no question that weather
helps reduce the level of deforestation
by keeping by making it less likely that
fires will spread but I think it's also
generally agreed that the actions taken
to reduce deforestation also played a
role in beginning to bring that curve
down I don't think anybody would say
that we have now cracked the problem
that we have turned the corner that is
the challenge of deforestation in
Indonesia and more broadly is behind us
far from it but I think we are seeing
that the kinds of partnerships it takes
to drive chains have been building and
the focus now is shifting how do you
take those global engagements and
translate them to concrete change on the
ground here I think is an important part
of thinking about social capital and
thinking about how social capital in a
global sector translates into real
change in the forest and that is a
recognition that that those global
commitments are the foundation for
change but then you have to get down to
the nitty-gritty of actually
implementing change in real places and
that's manifest now in a you know an
array of efforts that are all under the
umbrella of what's called the
jurisdictional approach which is buyers
and producers NGOs communities and local
governments in Indonesia the Cobell
patents the district governments within
a larger province who are working
together to figure out concretely how do
we end deforestation and fires in this
jurisdiction and what are each of us
going to do to help make that happen and
that allows everybody to get to the
specifics of what it really takes it
allows and it calls upon companies and
NGOs to convert a commitment to
conservation or to sustainability into a
compelling development proposition to
make this sure that this is a movement
that really does work for small
producers large producers local
governments communities in the places
where palm oil is grown
it is deeply challenging these are heart
problems and it is hard to affect change
in a sector like this globally but even
at that local level but I think there's
broad agreement that that's where the
future lies that you need these global
commitments as foundation and as
creating the ecosystem within which
change can happen and need you then
translate that into real terms for real
people at a jurisdictional and a
government level in in a way that can
work so that's the story of palm oil it
is industry one of now several examples
of how partners are finding a way to
work together in new kinds of
collaborations and to continue to work
together as they make progress or face
challenges in an evolving partnership
that is serious about change
this is absolutely team sport it's a
team sport that requires that everyone
on the team figure out a way to be
engaged with each other to figure out a
way to to forge these kinds of
commitments from a business perspective
there's no better voice on this than
Paul Polman who was for the last 10
years the chief executive of Unilever
End and really a leader in everything
that I've talked about from the consumer
goods forum commitment to the tropical
forest alliance to the development of
the jurisdictional approach but going
back to what Pam said at the beginning
what Paul emphasizes is that this is
about system change it's about change in
the way markets work and the
responsibilities all of us have as
consumers and citizens and in particular
about the role that business has to play
in that larger system to sustain the
system that makes their business
possible and I think there's exciting
potential in that and I think these are
the kinds of efforts that will not
deliver fast or easy solutions but will
be necessary to create the social
capital it takes to succeed in achieving
sustainability thank you very much Jim
and Pamela for this very informative
presentation and now we'll move on to
answering your questions
okay so the first question we have here
is what does it take to form a
partnership like this and put it in
motion the I think it's important to
recognize that the kinds of
collaborations we're talking about are
deeply difficult because you're asking
people to collaborate not only across
organizations with which is by itself
challenging but actually across sectors
and when you bring a big NGO for example
let's say a big activist NGO together
with a big local company you find that
you just you have many many differences
in basic culture in the basic
expectations for how the organization
works and the way that you relate to
each other and your expectations for
roles in the world so that so so making
these partnerships work and and you
would find that I'm sure similar things
in building partnerships between
competitors right which have a different
set of challenges so building these
kinds of partnerships number one takes a
real commitment on both sides and this
is not a matter of signing an MoU right
this is a matter of real commitment to
invest in what it takes to build a
partnership and of course like any
relationship the heart of that is trust
so the heart is you know dee is making
the commitment and making the investment
to really build trust between the two
organizations which starts at the top I
mean in my experience at David IVF by
far the strongest collaborations we had
at least at a global level were ones
where there was a strong engagement
between the CEOs as well as down through
the ranks so that the signal was clear
that the both organizations were serious
it requires of course then seriousness
about understanding what the interest
really are on both sides of the
conversation and how you can work
together to bring those interests
together so there's not magic here but
it but it is easily underestimated and I
think the successes you see in a story
like palm oil or similar stories come
out of that kind of commitment from the
top all the way down to really investing
in building understanding and building
trust and then being able to make
progress now let me just add to that I
completely agree on the main point that
it is trust and then the question is how
do you build trust what does it take to
build trust and and you know how do you
how do we make sure that the partners in
this are all credible and legitimate
partners you know but they're there for
the the similar benefits to humankind
and but I think it is helped by the fact
that some of the large non-governmental
organizations are really leading in a
way of working very hard recognizing
that it has to be that progress can only
be made if you can develop trust and
develop long term partnerships long term
understanding of each other's points of
view and and respect for those so along
those same lines I'm someone asked
regarding the palm oil example I was
recently at a clean tech conference
where they mentioned that is very
difficult for governments to actually
enforce guidelines and umbrella
companies and throughout the supply
chain for sustainable palm oil
how can one ensure that good intentions
are actually followed on and tracked and
are there technologies and processes
that you have seen to help yeah so I
would say this is an important point and
and it's it's characteristic of a global
sector like palm oil but also
particularly a commodity sector where
the products traded is once it goes into
the system has historically been
[Music]
invisible I mean it's been impossible to
know exactly where it came from so I
think two things there I mean one is
technology is increasingly our friend on
this and so there is increasing
transparency about where deforestation
is happening and an increasing ability
to know you know whose responsibility it
is so I think that's a crucial first
thing we are increasingly getting the
power to trace products more directly
from production all the way through the
system but then secondly this is for me
a good example of the evolution of roles
that I was talking about a few minutes
ago you see that NGOs who civil society
organizations who were in the early days
campaigning to get attention to
you now actually have quite an important
role in making sure that there's
accountability for delivering on the
commitments that are made and when we
were when I was at WWE put many years
ago we would periodically issue a
scorecard that said here's how every
company is doing and implementing its
commitments on what's a deforestation
and and a couple CEO said to me could
you do find a way to do that every
quarter because it really keeps people's
attention focused on it and and I think
NGOs have quite an important role in
these phases of a process in being a
vehicle for that kind of accountability
can I ask a question okay just just I'd
love your thoughts on blockchain and its
role and accountability on these kinds
of things so I think it's quite
impressive there were 45 minutes into
this class and we're just now mentioning
so I'm not a tech person I'm a lawyer
but but one of the things you find is in
traceability discussions is that sooner
or later everybody punches blockchain I
think the broader concept of distributed
Ledger's clearly has an important role
to play in providing a credible and an
accessible sort of chain of custody as
it were I mean ability to track products
or whatever as Tom Lehrer the comedian
once said life is like a sewer and let
you get out of it depends on what you
put into it and blockchain is the same
way right blockchain it can make sure
that the Train is clear but it can't
assure you the quality of the
information input at the beginning or
the product but at the beginning so you
still need that complement to what the
blockchain can do you know because I
dated myself for that the next question
is given the time and scale of our
current challenge we can't afford
organisations to take 8 to 12 years to
address issues like this so how can we
accelerate this process first
I'll just say we have to learn you know
I think we obviously relationships take
time because they're based on respect
they're based on listening they're
they're based on trust and and so you
can't fly in and fly out of a
relationship and have trust happen but
on the other hand I think for anything
in this sustainability realm we better
learn by doing and take home the best
lessons and shortcuts and not make the
same mistakes twice part of that part of
its 14 years was probably having to
create some new approaches and we'll
have to continue to do that but we
better learn yeah uh no no I think
that's exactly right I mean somehow
first of all these things are hard and
complicated right and and I think after
the sort of warm glow of commitments we
all I think recognized then Wow actually
translating those into changes is
difficult and I think we have to make
sure that we are from these first
efforts actually I'm learning how to do
it faster and bigger and I think that's
a big part of the challenge so in an
interesting way there's a role for the
research community in that you know
really paying attention keeping track
analyzing evaluating and sharing what's
learned about what's being done and that
that product of that effort can
hopefully be useful to everybody who is
engaged in this know and that not to add
on to everything but that's a that's a
rich area for collaboration between
universities and the civil society
sector governments and especially
companies in Canada because there's a
lot to learn about from companies who
are driving these kinds of changes
through their through their business and
I think a lot to learn together about
how to do that successfully thank you
our next question is what role does
social activism play in forging these
partnerships and kicking off these
initiatives for example with Nestle and
Unilever have kept quiet if it weren't
for the campaign's mentioned yes so I
think social activism is is crucial and
I think one of the great strengths of
the civil society sector
the diversity of organizations who are
able to group to therefore play diverse
roles and driving changes in the process
like this so there's no question that
that campaigns were important in in
directing attention to this issue and
then actually galvanizing action by
important actors and at the same time it
was crucial that there were make capable
conservation organizations in a position
to help countries and companies
translate those commitments into change
so that that ecosystem in itself is
actually quite an important part of this
how can circular economy initiatives
contribute to the conversation and
efforts around sustainability beyond its
value as a buzz phrase for marketing and
education I'm not an expert on the
circular economy but I think we can all
agree it's that's fundamental right I
mean you already we are with 7 billion
people we are straining the capacity of
the earth to support us and of course
exceeding that capacity in many places
and in many ways and our numbers and our
demand in particular will only grow and
so clearly we have to have an economy
that is less linear - use it throw it
away and and more circular and that's
the key to many of the things we're
talking about you know it's interesting
when you look at how human population
consumption has changed we had a billion
people on the planet in 1800 2 billion
people in the 1920s 3 billion people in
the 1950s today we have 8 plus billion
people were probably going to level off
around 10 or 11 billion people we worked
like crazy to meet the needs of all
those people during that very rapid
growth phase and we didn't think about
the problems of overusing resources
throwing away important products we
didn't create this
that were circular we almost didn't have
to and probably we felt like we didn't
have time to we were in a mad dash to
meet the needs of a rapidly growing
human population today we know what the
consequences are today we see the
leveling off of population today we
recognize that we can't throw things
away anymore that we have to use our
resources much more intelligently and so
the circle a circular economy
initiatives are a huge perspective of
are you a huge factor in doing that it's
not just using things more efficiently
reducing use but but and changing the
kinds of materials we use but but making
sure that they are never wasted so it's
a it's an exciting time I think for that
thank you the next question is how can
we engage corporations and form these
partnerships in regions where civil
activism and education around
sustainability is lacking well I mean if
partly anything that saves money and
that actually is is addressing the needs
of people in areas where there isn't any
activism are still going to be drivers
for this but the interesting thing about
about Jim's case study is that you see a
top-down force that is affecting what's
happening in places where there isn't
activism or where there isn't a
community-based interest in
sustainability it's a global world and
it's a global problem but I also think
that the recognition that there are real
benefits to doing things differently
that there are there are benefits in
terms of meeting the needs of people
saving money and and in many other areas
make it that alone a driver even if
people don't put the sustainability term
on it yeah I think the only thing I'd
add to that is I think a fundamental
principle to any effort like this is
that you you have to be able to frame
issues in terms that resonate
and in the place that you're talking
about ends and that means you know so
for example in human health has been a
much better entry point for many of
these issues than forest protection or
biodiversity conservation wise in many
markets and you need to be able to talk
in human health terms what does why is
this important for human health and you
need to be able to reach people on those
terms this so to take it for China for
example China is the largest buyer of
many commodities around the world but
Chinese consumers are increasingly
concerned particularly with food about
food safety
and that takes them traceability that
takes them to wanting to know more about
how the things they buy were produced
and so the entry point in China on these
issues may well be through traceability
and food safety as a as opposed to
initially through forest protection but
in each case it's a matter of so what
what are people worried about and how
are the how do you frame this issue in a
way that will resonate likewise there
you know many farmers around the world
who would like to save money on the
inputs they use in agriculture it costs
a lot to fertilize but if at the same
time by doing so by reducing how much
fertilizer you have to use there are
tremendous benefits for the environment
and so it's a win-win and there are lots
of wind wins our next question is how
can you contribute to such initiatives
and create social capital at the
individual level yeah this is it it in
basically every part of one's life
you can contribute I think and we have
this conversation a lot in an
educational institution like Stanford
how can we as individuals how can we as
a community make a big difference and
simply by the choices of what we eat and
what we drive and how we how we think
about our resource use etc we contribute
individually and we by doing so can
build a social movement among our
communities among our friends among our
families that is a very much a bottom-up
I think there's another question about
how we as individuals can can can create
change
at a scale that affects more communities
and that might be through your company
driving driving change in a company or
in an in an organization encouraging
people to think more systematically
about what's needed becoming systems
thinkers I think is a key to that yeah I
agree that in just to translate that
into the public case I mean they the
first law when we talk about what can
people do people usually think first
about voting and voting is crucial right
at any part of the world right the
pudding really matters because in the
end governments are and have to be at
the center of this but one of the things
you see in a case like pom well is that
consumers the decisions you make every
day in the grocery store the vote you
cast in the way you in the products you
choose really matters and you know when
you look at the hourglass that I showed
and those 500 companies it's easy to
feel maybe disempowered well it's of
those companies that matter but those
companies are listening to you I mean
those companies are very attuned to what
their consumers their customers are
thinking and so how you what you do in
the marketplace even if you do it
quietly really matters and if beyond
that you ask your retailer so you know
what are you doing about pom well or
about seafood or about those messages
get back so I think that you can
actually do all the things Pam talking
about the choices you make really do
ripple through the system to these large
levers thank you hey unfortunately we're
getting close to the hour so we'll have
to wrap up the Q&A session thank you
very much Jim and Pamela for sharing
your knowledge with our participants
today for those of you who have
indicated an interest in the program our
team will be reaching out with more
information and you can always visit us
at global impact stanford.edu thank you
all for joining us today and have a
great rest of your week